so [ __ ] I don't care how much you love
this guy and how much you think he is
essential or whatever fairy tale you've
concocted in your head about any of
these people any of our leaders that you
love so much yet have never met I mean
all of these people would want nothing
to do with you
the Obamas the Trump's they wouldn't
want anything to do with you can you
imagine you're disgusting family your
marinara sauce covered fingers do you
understand the way these people [ __ ]
look at you when will you when do you
think you people will wake up is it when
you're all in camps I mean truly at what
point do you understand that these
people [ __ ] look at you like a
[ __ ] rat scurrying across a busy
street they're puzzled by you they're
confused almost they watch you run
across the street and if you make it
they go huh cool and if you get hit by a
car and you get squashed in the middle
of the street ha ha
they don't necessarily rejoice but it
doesn't [ __ ] up their day at all I think
we all need to grow up now I really
believe that I think if we don't grow up
we're gonna be in trouble as a species
and if we keep thinking that these
people give a [ __ ] about us and that
they care about us on any level at all
we're going to we're going to delude
ourselves to death and I think it's a
big [ __ ] problem and I don't care
whether it's a Oh see any of the people
that we've elected to be the narcissists
of the week and to tell us all how we
live how to live all of these people are
after for the most part their own power
and they're not really looking out for
you they believe things in the abstract
that could help you
but when Bernie Sanders who I like and
respect you know treats Joe Biden like a
statesman in that debate instead of
turning around and going you are the
[ __ ] problem
how did Trump get elected by going to
jeb bush and destroying his own party
Trump destroyed the Republicans he
destroyed the bush dynasty they they
limped Jeb limped out of those debates
that young Bush still can't get elected
in Texas the little kid tried in a
congressional race the the the damage
done to that name might be irreparable
and they were the biggest pull it one of
the biggest political dynasties in our
country and Trump got rid of him and he
did that by being rude I mean he did
that by saying things that made you go
whoa but you have Bernie Sanders kind of
treating chill by didn't like a
statesman cuz they're friends or
whatever
Trump was friends with Hillary he didn't
care he didn't care they were friends he
played golf with Bill they you know he
went to a wedding he went to their wet
lake they they came to his wedding he
was friends with them it didn't matter
didn't matter to him and yeah you know
maybe Sanders is more integrity great
that doesn't win that does it win it's
very hard to root for the left because
they they're so allergic to winning they
are so they are born losers they are
incapable of [ __ ] winning I mean
Trump may still win the next election
how hilarious is that we have a
worldwide preventable pandemic in this
country a stock market crash
alikes which we haven't seen in a
generation and we're going into a global
depression and Trump may still win he
might pull it out he the record he has
to run on is the worst record of any
maybe president
I mean has anyone the wholesale
destruction of the American economy and
our complete way of life we can't leave
our houses we owe the whole country got
suspended and he still could pull it out
does that give you an idea of how
pathetic the other side is how they're
quibbling and their infighting is so
repulsive they're so annoying to most
people even me who realizes and has
realized a trump again is a hawkster
he's peddling his wares to people that
you know see him as some type of avatar
but but essentially he's a huckster if
you don't see that even if you think
he's funny
even if you hate the other side you see
Trump as a huckster I think the
difference is that a lot of people out
there go yeah but he's our hawkster he's
my like he's he's ripping off everybody
on behalf of us if that were only the
case if that were only the case I could
be like great but you can't leave your
house because we didn't order the tests
and the masks cuz you didn't care see
they want to spook the stock market by
even talking about a pandemic you know
because it didn't matter because
everything was good the gravy train was
rolling along and you know so again it's
a mistake if you if you're unwilling to
admit that you're you've left the realm
of logic